I'm a little bit late today.
I was going to actually be a little bit
early. Uh but I have some good news. So
this might be surprising to you because
usually accounts get this way way way
earlier.
I just with this following
got access to
monetization
which is kind of cool.
So, uh, yeah, I, uh, I went and I
submitted one thing for this. I have no
plans whatsoever to monetize all of you.
All my stuff is still free. All the
educational stuff is still free. No paid
courses, no [ __ ] but I put
something a little uh, a little
something together for businesses so
that they can get like an entrylevel
support chat thing. So, we'll see if
this goes through.
But yeah, that took longer than expected
to set up. Uh, and anyways,
for some reason I posted a random like
completely completely random
plot
like at the end of my stream. I just
posted this random plot and
apparently Twitter really likes plots.
Like I
I don't understand how it is that I post
like really full detailed technical
articles on stuff and then I post some
random plot and this happens. What is
going on with the algorithm? Um,
but anyways, I'll show you what happened
with that plot and I'll explain what it
is uh because I may as well.
And it's not it is exciting actually. It
is very exciting, but it's going to take
a little bit more work. And that's what
we're going to be doing today.
this is the plot, right?
So the problem is that I actually I
forgot to run this for long enough,
funny enough. Uh so this stopped at 107
billion, but it's kind of interesting.
You know, you can see this thing has an
exponential shape and then at the very
end, this is learning rate and healing
down to nothing. So you're not really
expecting much here. Uh this is the
exact same run again except now I think
that because the learning rate and
kneeling is different since it's a
longer run. Uh it's not doing as well.
So I mean we're going to see whether
this like has the same takeoff just
longer or what goes on here. Uh I'm just
going to let this keep running for now
and we're going to fix up the
experimental setup today so we can do
more experiments and do this at proper
scale. Um, but the cool thing that this
was here, so this was
this was our puffer 300 baseline for
neural MMO where we get 8.5 score which
is level 8.5 in the game. Uh, the
maximum is 25. So this is not remotely a
solved benchmark. And then this is
Mingru on Puffer 4. Still the Python
back end, but this is the fundamentally
new architecture.
So uh without even retuning hypers. So
you know the question is going to be can
we now do better with this new
architecture and this would be a
confirmation both that the architecture
is good uh and then also know it would
say something uh well it would also just
like push forward state-of-the-art
because this is our hardest benchmark
right now. The one thing that I kind of
wanted to highlight here which I thought
was pretty cool.
So you see that in the old 30 baseline,
it actually takes 5 billion steps before
it starts learning. And the only time I
have ever seen this start learning
instantly
uh is this run here, which is like this
really janky off policy experiment where
you kind of screw things up and it's
super unstable.
So the fact that we got this level of
learning on policy with just a different
architecture immediately is kind of
cool.
Now, I don't know what's up. If it's
just learning rate or what we have to do
differently, but this is pretty cool.
Hello, Kyouong. Welcome. Yeah, this is
what this this is what the secret plot
was. It was Minw.
Um I forgot to run it for long enough,
right? So, I'm rerunning it and it's
going to be different and it's probably
going to take way longer because the
learning rate in nailing is different.
But yeah, we're going to see what
happens with this.
Uh, it's also faster, which is kind of
cool to note. Like even without any
optimizations, it's already faster.
Yeah.
Well, it's not just I still need to do
hyperp optimization. It could be better.
It's also like this was doing well and
then I ran I didn't run the experiment
for long enough, right? It was kind of
fortunate actually because otherwise I
would have seen this and I would have
concluded it isn't any good. But it's
actually, it looks like it's just the
learning rate tuning here that is a
little bit off.
So, I think this is exciting. And the
goal for today is going to be to get uh
2048 working nicely with this setup. And
we're going to run some benchmarks. And
Kung's here, so I'm going to ask him a
few questions about that.
So, yeah, that's the plan for today.
Okay. And then also the other thing that
I mentioned right when I started the
stream is I finally got eligibility for
uh monetization on X, which is kind of
cool. So I have a couple things planned
with that.
So
let's get your PR merged. And then I'm
actually I'm going to merge your stuff
into 40 as well today. K.
another business income stream.
Yeah, I'm uh I'm gonna offer I'm
offering one subscription service on
there which is only for businesses.
Everything is still free for individuals
and uh everything is still MIT licensed.
There's no shenanigans going on, but I'm
offering like a cheaper like entry
levelvel uh priority chat thing for
businesses. That'll be live in a few
days.
It might plateau. No, actually it
doesn't. Honory, let me explain. Let me
explain why that is uh not the correct
conclusion.
So you see this is zero learning rate at
the bottom. So this by definition this
has to be flat here.
So what hap typically happens is you get
this type of like plateauing in your
runs all the time just because of the
learning rate in kneeling when you use
cosine decay.
So really it actually was accelerating
up until this very end where it like
completely drops off.
How much does it cost premium chat
launching at 200?
It's not for individuals.
I actually I explicitly do not want uh
anybody in the community like buying it
just to get access to a special chat or
whatever. It is like intended
specifically for businesses and
businesses who want a much much cheaper
way to get some level of service than
our normal contracts.
Okay, let's get Kyouung's PR merged.
418.
Oh, okay. It's just a little PR fuel.
Uh,
football. Who makes that?
Sega.
So, when Sega really wants it to exist,
then it'll exist
basically.
I'm on the wrong tab. My bad, Jung. Let
me focus here.
What does it offer? Uh, access to a
priority group DM.
So, the idea is that instead of having a
our like typical minimum 10,000 a month
contract, and really I don't think we're
going to be doing this for much longer.
Um, it's really not worth my time to be
doing like these size contracts. Really,
we're focused a lot more on like custom
simulation development at this point,
which is substantially more expensive.
So, I I think that it's just going to be
like a nice entry way for companies to
get like some level of additional
support while not just being like
filtered through the whole gigantic
Discord that moves super fast.
And we'll see how it goes. It's
experimental, right? If a bunch of
companies sign up and like it, then
we'll keep it. If like a couple people
sign up and they're like, "Eh, you know,
really, it doesn't make sense to have
something that's like this. It's kind of
like it makes more sense to either do
something larger or nothing at all." And
we'll get rid of it. We'll see. That's
an experiment.
But, you know, what is definitely going
to happen is that these contracts are
going to go up over time. So, having
some sort of entryway seems like a good
idea to me.
Have you tried any local benchmarking
tools or any profilers? Of course, we do
all sorts of local profiling with Puffer
Lib.
Okay. And now what we're going to do is
let me get let me get my term set up.
And I think we're going to merge this
into 40 and we're going to get some
experiments going.
Do not know the possibilities of RL.
Yeah. So this is not our focus for
clientele though man. But our focus
right now we are not trying to convince
companies to come do RL.
All right. Like I'm not trying to sell
companies on like, hey, this is why you
should do RL. This is for companies that
know what RL is, kind of want to do it.
Maybe they've tried and it's hard,
right? This is for them
cuz otherwise like I'd have to spend way
more of my time on like marketing and
like accessibility and stuff. And I
frankly I just don't want to do that. Uh
I'm a scientist. I'm an engineer. So I
want to spend as much of my time as
possible working on advancing science
and tech. And then for the people who
want assistance with that their services
okay, we have 40 and let us open
a quick PR
this already. We already did the full
2048 in, right?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure we did.
So, this is going to be from 3 0 into
40.
Let me make sure I do this right.
Not automatically.
Is Kyouung an advisor? Kyouung is a
contributor.
Uh, and Kyouong has been a contributor
for a long time. He's worked with me
back since neural MMO days during my
PhD.
Hiring into the puffer team. So, we
currently do not hire full-time honory.
We hire people uh as contractors for
specific projects. So when um when we
have a company that wants a project with
us then I pull people from people who I
like people who I've worked with either
throughout my PhD or from open source
and puffer lab you know people who've
demonstrated that they can handle large
projects
and I hire them on for that
benchmarking and rust compilation kind
of kind of sucks. Ah, that's what you
get for using Rust.
Our comp our compilations are instant in
C.
That's just language diff, my friend.
That is one of the uh largest marks
against Rust. I would say
I love that in C I can just compile a a
dev build and have runtime checks for
all the memory bugs and things and then
I can just remove those flags and have a
fast build that doesn't have those
checks and not have to like mess with
any of my programming like the way that
I build stuff at Oh,
yeah. And I think after this for
reference as well I think after this
we're going to have I think starting in
40 we're going to have a rule that uh
it's only like bug fixes that get put
into major releases
and new content like you know new
environment stuff is going to have to
get merged into dev branch and then dev
branch will just be instantaneously
uh there and then we'll work to keep the
dev branch more stable.
Uh, this is small enough that I can
probably just do this, right?
3.0
them from base
on E10.
killing this version.
I know.
I'm actually very curious how you handle
timeouts, Kyouong.
Because like it seems to me like this
would produce a bunch of jank situations
where it runs really long experiments
early on for no reason.
But like presumably not right
decknum ms
If it produces nan, then sweep moves on.
But what if it just runs a really long
experiment, man? Like if you have one
E10,
because it can only its prediction of
cost is not going to be very good early
on, right?
Okay, this numbum mini batches thing is
going to be uh in 40.
This is a 40 change.
Then this
Huh.
You reduce to 1 eus 14. Interesting.
Okay.
Welcome, Rat Swag.
Yeah. So, I messed with um I did a
little messing around with the policy.
We're going to have to fix a couple
things, but that's fine. We'll do that
today.
Current change.
Yeah, this clip coefficient is super
sketchy. By the way,
are you renting your own compute?
Right next to the puffer fish, you see
these? We got these servers and then
we've got these two servers up there all
on the wall behind me.
And we got like one unexpected contract.
Um, we got one unexpected rush order
contract this week as well that I'm
going to finish and then probably that
will go towards buying us another bigger
server
right. So this one is
uh we got rid of the cosign and kneeling
scheduler
company contracts main source of income.
Yep.
We mostly build custom sims
and then we get obviously we don't just
build the sim, we also make RL agents
train on the sim. That's the whole idea
of puffer is we're quite good at that.
Tell them how many experiments you run
on these. [laughter]
Let's just say that each one of the
bigger servers can consume more data
than all of chat GPT pre-training
[sighs]
quite easily in fact.
Uh okay. So this is at min. So I think
we're going to keep yours on this one,
Kyouong.
And then
And I think we're going to try to move
away from heavy ball as well in 40 cuz
uh Muan is in torch now. We'll have to
do a PF comparison, but I think that's
going to be the goal
cuz the compilation is really obnoxious.
I really don't want any form of
compilation uh by default in the loop. I
want you to like install Puffer Lib and
I want it to run instantly.
Look at this. It flipped it on me. I
made this PR go from 300 to 40 and it
[ __ ] flipped it on me.
It is so obnoxious.
How's Mingru?
Uh, Mingru is doing well enough. I'd say
we got one cool thing, but now I'm
working on uh getting this to
uh I'm getting the stuff that we need to
test it integrated from 3 into 4
changes into 40 from 40 merge.
Okay, merge.
Cool.
Get rid of this boro merge.
Oh, and I also have to do your uh your
min learning rate change in Python
Python land.
GPU rack. [laughter]
Nope, they we have 4090s and uh 5090s.
If you want to have uh well, if you want
to be very amused, go look up the
performance difference and the price
difference between 4090s and 800s for
what we do. The 4090s are literally
faster than the A00s at a tiny fraction
of the price.
The Expost assumed it was Mingru. You
are correct. The pink one was in fact
Mingru, but there's some learning rate
shenanigans
to be dealt with.
Okay, we have to do something about this
Kung because this is like 14 megs worth
of weights just for the uh the default
Paul.
I think we might just have to make it so
that um
I don't know. And we might have to make
it so that um like the weights only go
on the website repo or something.
3x speed your stream.
How much do you typically pay
contractors
on average? Out of curiosity, half of
it, Jess. 50/50.
And you're not expected to do like the
entire thing solo. I advise and I
occasionally will help with engineering
as well.
making it easy via pip. Yeah, I agree.
And we definitely have to do that in 40
cuz the puffer is getting a little bit
fatty.
I got to lean him down a little bit.
I want to have multiGPU sweeps going
today as well. Does that make sense? K.
do a multi-GPU
against uh G2048. We'll run six GPUs
against it.
Uh did I break?
Yeah.
The only thing we got to figure out is
this Muan shenanigans.
H maybe we can punt on it actually.
Maybe we can punt on this. We will do it
after.
Chess is learning. Waiting on Spencer to
unbreak selfplay. Sounds good.
No, I did my Saturday marathon and then
just crashed yesterday.
And by crashed, I mean I did 60 sets and
then crashed. But
kind of just end up lifting weights for
hours on end on Sunday until I no longer
feel like completely stressed out.
I end up getting in basically a full
week's worth of a training program. So,
you know, even if I um skimp on some of
my sets throughout the week, I kind of
have it banked.
It's so funny though. Every time I post
this, like a bunch of nerds come out of
the woodwork to tell me that it's like a
a really bad training program when it's
not
like, oh, doing any more than like 10 or
12 sets is suboptimal. Yeah, per body
part.
I see you use both Neptune and WB. How
do you use each one be for model
registry? Nope. We just support two
different backends for an Aldo. Uh we're
kind of waiting to see because Neptune
has alluded to deprecating some of their
free stuff in uh well in a month or so.
And if they deprecate it so that there
is if there is no free version of
Neptune and none of our current clients
complain, I'm just going to strip it as
a back end and we're going to go back to
Wand because like that's ridiculous.
You know, I'm not going to have a
default support for a paid logging tool
on our free state-of-the-art
reinforcement learning library, right?
Yeah, and the new wii update actually
looks pretty good.
Got back into lifting and I'm happy
camper. Like day was rough though. Yeah.
So, what I do is I do very, very minimal
leg training. The only leg training I
really do is I do a couple things on
Sunday and then I do my deadlifts,
speaking of which I got to go get my
daily one in. Um,
and then I run a lot. So, my running is
my leg training.
I was lazy this morning. I only did I
only did a 5k. I didn't do my normal 10.
What is wrong with torch?
I have a feeling their dev build is just
slow as well.
Oh, let's go take a look at our our PR
in the meantime to see if they got to
it. Uh, GitHub
this tab.
Massive calves. Yeah, I don't train my
calves at all at all. And they're not
like they're not bad. It's just from the
running.
Zero people.
Zero.
Okay. Well, I guess we'll I guess we'll
probably have to make a local version
then uh with the assumption that they're
just going to take forever.
It's kind of insane that they're like
prioritizing the Python back end to the
point that they're not implementing
their [ __ ] in C++ anymore because like
they literally just make everything
slower without compile mode on. So the
point of torch was to be eager mode and
like they just make everything slow
without compile on
by doing that.
Got to tag that guy.
Which guy?
It wasn't ever assigned to anybody,
right? Uh this one.
Yeah, this never got assigned to
anybody.
This just got like bullshitted and then
I
reid I redid it here.
I got sick of fighting their CLA for
hours.
Okay, so to do today is going to be uh
make experiments run in Python and then
it's going to be have stable local
version of Muon that does not require me
to compile PyTorch horribly. But I don't
even know what it's doing right now.
Who is on the team? Uh, they replied,
but I don't think they replied about
merging it, right? They replied to me
about like setup and stuff.
Welcome, Peru.
Let me get a cup of coffee and get a uh
another couple sets in while I do this.
Going to do some light light training
today.
Is torch even doing? I think we're going
to stop this thing and we're just going
to get it to work from a local build. I
mean, uh, a default build cuz this is
ridiculous.
So, we're going to have to fight this a
little bit um so that the Python builds,
but then we'll be able to fix both the
Python and the C++ and we'll be able to
compare them.
what is wrong
with this?
Move on options
The goal this week is to deal with a lot
less [ __ ] than last week because
last week really was starting to burn me
out with um not even the amount of work,
but just the amount of [ __ ] you
know, with the C++ and all that. Like I
want to get back to running experiments
and writing C and even writing kernels
was less [ __ ] than dealing with
torch.
It's just it's not very good C++.
Honestly, it's not even that it's like
the C++ is bad, but then on top of that,
it's actually pretty like big tech over
like bulky, bloated C++
at the same time.
It's like, yeah, of course nobody likes
the C++ back end.
pin memory. Oh, uh, Peru, I have one as
well on that, right? So, we got that to
work here. Let me show you. Did I not
show you this actually?
And I still have your uh your PR in
mind.
I not have in here. Anyways, I got it to
work. You can pin memory. Um I don't
know if I haven't tried it across
threads though.
So I got it. Yes, you can pin memory uh
like for the ends and give the pointer
to an end. I have not tried it across
threads. Yes, it improves transfer times
by about double.
Multi-threading with pin memory. Good
job, man. That's actually very useful.
So,
okay, let me see. What am I looking at?
We've got
and copy
what is this showing me? Just I see one
big copy, right? I'd need something for
comparison.
Is this supposed to be showing me that
it's one copy instead of two copies?
We spend time in N or block running the
LSTM. Okay, cool. Peru, can you answer
me one question? Um, is it possible to
buffer memory transfers? So while the
forward pass for the network is running
can we be loading more data from other
ends onto the GPU. So basically instead
of double buffering just the
environments we do one more step and we
also buffer the transfer onto CUDA
even with non-blocking equals true we
are just blocked. Well, of course you're
just blocked here though because you
actually need that data, right? But I
mean, let's say that if instead of 4096
ms, if you have 8192 ms, right? And then
you cuda the first 4097 uh 4096 blocks
and then the network starts running the
forward pass. But at the same time, can
we have the observations for the other
4096M be going to CUDA? I think you
should be able to buffer that.
Can I safely train with 40 branch?
It's not stable, Jess. I wouldn't tr I
wouldn't try it yet.
This is really for me for dev for now. I
can run some experiments sometimes, but
I wouldn't like Yeah.
How does that work with the eval and
train loop? Well, during training, you
don't need any device transfer. That's
fine. Like, you don't need any of it.
Uh, and then in evaluation, it's just
you double buffer, right? So, you have a
block of environments that's running and
you have a block of environments uh that
is like currently being consumed. I
already have this working with um puffer
lib Python version. It's just that the
transfers don't also get buffered to the
GPU. They only get buffered from CPU.
if you can point me to a PR. What PR do
you want me to point you to though?
What? Like this has just been a feature
for a long time.
Segments in each block are justly
waiting on the end and getting the
action from the GPU. Yeah, of course
they are right because you don't have
double buffering implemented. If you
just look at the 30 vectorization
and this is described in the papers as
well that I've written, right? This is
basically it works similarly to endpool
but with some additional optimizations.
Uh
yeah. So like when you receive it's not
just like uh like receive from all M's.
It like goes through the workers to see
which of them are done.
It actually will go through the workers
to see which ones are done and form a
batch. But the other ones are still
stepping in the background. But the
thing is that they are writing to
they're not writing to shared memory.
And then if they were writing to shared
memory, like once a batch is done, we
could also have this thing just move it
to the GPU.
We'd have to figure out how to do it a
little bit, but I think it would be
awesome. And with threads, I think it
makes sense as well. A little harder to
do with multipro.
Just saying
Eval loop outside taking this batch
separate.
Wait, there's the eval loop outside
taking this batch.
So the way that it works is it's like
let's say you do reset on all your ends,
right? You call reset. Now you have 8192
observations that are ready. So you take
the first 4096,
you run them through the network.
Okay?
And now you have a batch of actions. So
you call step on the environment with
those actions, but you don't wait for
the observations to come back. You
already go and start consuming the next
4096 observations, right? And by the
time you've produced actions for those,
you should have observations ready in
the previous one. But right now, those
observations are only ready for you on
the CPU. They're ready in a big like
array, right? So if instead once they're
ready, they were also transferred to
GPU, then by the time that you are have
a batch of actions, you should already
have a batch of observations on the GPU
that are ready.
You advise undergraduates to drink less.
Was that from experience?
Yes,
I am proud of this. This is this is a
true statement. I got through undergrad,
grad school, too for that matter. But I
got through undergrad
uh without touching anything but alcohol
in California.
So, I figure that's not bad.
I did drink too much.
Could
you just batch per end instance? No, you
have to batch a lot more than that, man.
CUDA streams. It should be possible.
Why do you need CUDA streams?
It should just be a dot like two device
with non-blocking.
Python overhead is very small. Well,
there's going to be there's zero Python
overhead in C++, right?
We should be able to get what is it?
It's 32 gigs a second PCIe, isn't it? Or
is it 64?
Helps synchronize.
We might need to do that manually.
Think the non-blocking does that under
the hood for you. I'm not positive.
Oh, did I not I probably just didn't
export it like a dummy, right?
Uh
that class.
32 gigs a second.
That's the transfer, right? That's a
host device on PCIe.
What's the amount of data we should be
able to transfer per second? Isn't it 32
gigs?
maxed out on well the thing that matters
Peru is that um the thing that matters
is threading versus multiprocessing
because it's it's really annoying to do
with the Python multipprocessor business
back end.
Oh, this probably needs to be compiled
with um
with the C++, right?
Yeah, I'm dumb. I just
there. We'll fix that.
Not sure my initial intuition using lib
torch.
Uh so Peru it's really obnoxious to
figure out how to do shared memory when
you have a multipprocessing backend in
Python because having
shared arrays for multipprocessing and
pinning them is
yeah there's a there's a tough bit with
that.
I remember spending quite a while trying
to figure it out.
Well, it's not it's a language
restriction in Python that you can't do
native multi-threading, right?
Like you couldn't implement it with
threads in Python and have it be fast,
at least before Python 314.
walk through the court puffer once we
get 40. Maybe Jess.
No, this is separate Peru. This is
totally separate.
The point of doing um the entire eval
and train in C++ is then I know for sure
there is no Python overhead and um I
don't need to use torch compile which
adds like annoying startup time and when
you try to start optimizing torch
compile it's actually harder than just
writing C++ believe it or not and also
like we're going to need custom kernels
so we're going to have to write some
torch binds anyways and now we can even
test those from C++ ++ and test them
from Python.
Like I guess it is technically possible.
Star puffer. Do star the puffer. Oh
yeah. For anybody who's new around here,
feed the puffer a star. He's hungry. It
helps out a lot.
Graph go up.
5K this year. I'd hope so. I'd hope so.
That'd be nice.
Options does not name a type.
Really?
Somebody linked me a Minecraft
environment that was like 2,000 steps
per second. like, "Hey, look, it's super
fast now."
I also I found a cool game this weekend
as well. Actually, I'll show this on
stream because this is like this is so
freaking cool. Um like for uh thinking
about research and stuff. So, somebody
basically made neural MMO, but they did
it with scripted bots and they'd like
made an actual full game, not a research
environment. So, this is like a full-on
MMO,
but like and you can group with players
and you can do whatever, but it's all
scripted agents. So, it's like as close
to a multiplayer MMO as you can possibly
have, but it's a single player game.
So, I don't know. This is going to have
some really cool ideas in it as well for
uh Neural MMO 4, I'm sure.
And I can also play it and have it be
fun without it being straight heroine,
which is kind of nice.
Yeah, it's local and yeah, I think they
have mod support,
but I mean it's the same problem you're
going to have with every game, right?
Which is not being designed to be run in
an RL setting like this higherf. You can
always just like get around it by
spinning up a 100,000 cores, but
I don't know. Maybe we'll do that
eventually. That's like quite a bit.
100,000 cores.
Yeah, that's still a lot of money.
[laughter]
If you can solve that problem, you let
me know. But
I don't know how you run arbitrary slow
code.
Okay.
The clones of Minecraft.
Yeah. So basically open offer, right? If
anybody has one that is actually fast,
which is probably going to be trainable
from state, that would be an amazing
addition to puffer lib.
If it's like at all a reasonable version
as well that has like, you know, some
usable amount of stuff in it and it's
actually fast and you can get agents.
Like if you let's say that you just got
the terrain gen uh reasonable in like
basic caves and stuff and you got an
agent that like goes and makes a pickaxe
and goes and get diamonds or gets iron
or whatever like that would immediately
qualify you for contracting work with
puffer as well like that size of a
project.
So,
it's pretty much just like the qualss
are pretty much just having written a
clean like a version with clean simple
code and like working RL uh for a
medium-sized uh custom sim project cuz
that's what the client jobs look like.
I mean, you do also have to be like not
completely skitso. You have to be able
to work professionally,
but main thing is being able to deliver
something like that autonomously pretty
quick.
Is there a template for Jack's place
environment?
Gimmnax puffer random crafter.
Yeah. So, I have not maintained that
particularly well. Um, so let me know if
there's any bugs with it. But yeah, you
should you can use that, right? The
gymnax puffer end. I mean, you can
really use whatever you want, frankly.
Um, because our API, it's just a
standard vecend interface. So, if you
just match our ve interface, you're good
to go.
Minecraft server that runs on ESP32.
That's just the server, though.
Uh, I mean, we don't need
there's really not much more you need
than the server, though. You basically
just need obsizes.
It can't be written as a server though
that you have to connect to with a
client, right? It has to be like one
block of code. I honestly I think you
could probably do
you could probably do like a decent
Minecrafty end in no more than a few
thousand lines of code
for sure. It would be a bigger project
than like it'd probably be a project
that's like bigger than Terraform or
whatever, but like I wouldn't think it
would be any bigger than Neural MMO or
MOA.
The rendering for the demo might be a
pain in the ass because um you kind of
do have to do a little bit of custom
rendering. You can't just render
everything as cubes and have it work.
But that's not anything to do with the
agent.
Ah, yeah. There you go. Thanks, Kong.
Use that
cuz either my math is wrong or you
figured out O of N scaling for multi-
aent. What do you mean O of N scaling
for multi- aent? Multi-agent is O of N O
of the number of agents.
watched one of your YouTube vids
yesterday and had to follow Puffer super
sweet. Welcome. Come build some cool
environments with us. Most of the things
on uh Puffer AI are communitymade. Like
most of these environments are by
contributors. You kind of just can jam
some low-level gamedev and advance RL in
the process.
Thinking of moving my Jack's ends to
puffer.
I've been set up as use VMAP for the
parallel ends. I will use will I lose
that speed as it uses multi-thread?
Uh no. What you would do with that is
you wouldn't you would not use one
thread per environment.
You'd run the so you run end instances
serially but you do like here if we're
going to do like an 8 core setup with
8,000 environments. Each core is going
to run 1,000 environments on a single
thread. And it runs them serially. Sure.
But like it's still fast unless your
environment is really compute inensive.
I mean a a very easy test of this is
like what's the steps per second you get
from your implementation if you just run
uh one environment on one core in C
because it turns out a lot of the time
it's just way faster than you would
think
particularly if your jacks have like a
bunch of branching or stuff in them like
um craft ax you'd think oh it's
massively parallel it runs on the GPU
but actually I guarantee you that M is
slower than it would be on CPU
depends how much branching and stuff you
have, man. So, like if you look at
Craftex, that thing only runs a 100,000
steps per second because it has a ton of
branching. It would be because it's a
game, right? It would be millions of
steps per second. Probably like a
million per core, couple million a core
depending how you optimize it. Um, on
the CPU,
right? But now if you give me an
environment that like you can do the
napkin math on flops and it's more flops
than your CPU can produce but it has no
branching then that's obviously a GPU
environment right now. The cool thing is
you don't have to do one way or the
other. You can just plug your
environment in and use Puffer's training
algorithm either way.
Right?
Like I did this little experiment in 40
where I wrote a CUDA environment and
yeah we can just train on a CUDA
environment because it's a veend
interface right it doesn't really matter
what you have as long as you have a ve
interface
and then what do you want to move them
to puffer for? Is it getting hard to
build them in jacks? Like what do you
want? Right.
For anything that's not trivially pure
array ops, it is easier to write C than
jacks. I will say that.
I want to use your trans loop and tools
and then just bind your jack to a
puffer. Right. Just standard ve
interface and try it out.
>> Yeah, just write a simple end binding.
It's a few lines of code.
Puffer really doesn't do any magic.
Does it have to be in C? Uh you do not
have to write your M's in C to use
Puffer Lib. You are free to bind however
you like. We have our default binding
set up for C and we take contributions
in C because that keeps the project much
much simpler and frankly C is just a
really good language for sim. It
prevents people from doing a lot of
stupid things that they would just
naturally do in higher level languages
even in C++. Um so yeah like you can
write stuff in other languages if you
want you'll have to just do the same
sort of binding as we have set up for C
though
you know you ultimately all you need is
a veend interface exposed to uh exposed
to the training layer which is currently
Python it will be a C++ option in puffer
but there's really not any magic puffer
is not like a gigantic library where you
have to like you know guess how on earth
you're going to be able interact with
it. Like pretty much any question you
ask, there's somewhere between 10 and
100 lines of code somewhere that just do
the thing that you're asking about.
You can do stuff in Odin if you want.
You're going to have to figure out the
only thing you're going to have to
figure out that's mildly annoying with
other languages. Let me show you.
So this is our end binding file in the
current public release of uh puffer lib.
So this is the Python C API and we use
this to bind from Python to C and we
also handle like we run the loop over
environments in C using this as well.
you need to have some sort of binding
from your M to um to Python
is the only thing
so you can run PyTorch models.
I don't know. It kind of depends what
your objective is, right? If you're
trying to like learn RL and just jam
some low-level dev, the C is awesome. If
you're like messing around with Odin,
you really want to do Odin, then like
sure. But I don't really want to take
contributions if that's your objective.
If you want to like build an environment
and PR it really don't want to take
contributions in other languages at the
moment because then I have to just make
the build system so much bigger, right?
Like cuz then the build system has to
support multiple languages. It just
bloats the project when really like
simple C just takes you so far and it's
so bloody easy, right?
That's pretty much the only reasoning.
Like if you actually look at some of the
end code and see it's like so so so
easy.
I mean of all the languages I could
choose, right? Like if I had chosen to
do puffer lib in Odin, like that would
probably work, right? I could have
chosen Nim. There are like a few
languages I could have chosen, but you
know, I'm not going to choose like a
niche a niche hobbyist language, right,
that isn't widely used. So, of all of
the major languages I could choose, C is
just the best choice.
C++ people do too much stupid, overly
complicated stuff. Um, any of the higher
level langs are just too slow to use on
their own. You need manual memory
management.
So, probably like just C is the only
option based off of that.
And the C is nice. I have very very few
complaints about uh the C in general for
this.
I don't know. Maybe string processing
sucks in C. That's about the only thing
I can think of off the top of my head.
Okay, this is the last thing that we
needed here was the min learning rate
thing, right?
Yep. We have to update this one cycle.
What is that?
This would be a very easy thing to
ablate actually.
So yeah, Daniel, if you want to try this
thing out, this would be like a super
easy set of experiments to run. You just
grab Puffer 3 and then like run some
environments and see if you can get any
speed ups with uh sweeps.
I would actually believe that this could
make a big difference
cuz this is basically cosine. This is
cosine right here, right? So this is
cosine
decay with warmup.
Have you only tried cosine? No.
We had linear and then we tried a couple
other things. And it seemed to me that
of the things that I tried, it made a
very big difference to have learning
rate decay versus not to have it, but
the specific method didn't matter a lot.
Um, I think I also tried like the the
step like the constant and then decrease
at the end or whatever. Uh, but I didn't
try anything that like warms up super
high and then decreases. I didn't try
anything with warm up.
reduce on plateau. You can try it.
The thing is you'd have to define what
is the plateau. You'd have to use like a
environment score or perf or something
because uh your loss function is not
going to look like a plateauing thing in
RL.
Like your loss function is going to look
weird. R out.
maximum
number of epochs in a cycle. Oh,
Oh, I see. LR ratio is this. This is
fine.
So we just do this.
Hello. Can we ask questions? Of course.
Why do you think I stream all the dev?
the wrong one. This has got to be Python
puffer.
That effect is only ever brought up by
dumb people who think that they're
talking to even dumber people.
Welcome
OD.
Pretty good.
Pretty good training.
That is a full solve.
So that is a full solve with the new
codebase.
Uh, we should be able to do 2048
and we'll have to configure uh configure
a couple things.
size is 512.
Right? So this goes away.
attribute initial state. Right? So now
we have to figure out the policy
and how we're going to handle this.
Yeah. So, right here, I kind of just did
um
I guess we can kind of just
hunt on this a little bit.
Yeah. So, this is the default policy.
Let me see if I can just get this into
uh
Well, what if I just do it like this?
Can I just do um
this
and then I just do self 20
selfg G
G
This has encode observations.
Now, let's just make sure we don't mess
up the um
all too crucial
forward passes.
This has Ford Eval and Ford train.
Yeah, let's do it this way.
So now we can just do self. So Ford is
just going to be
self dot uh
>> [sighs]
>> Okay. So now we have hopefully fixed the
policy.
Hey, it runs.
Oh, and it runs
reasonably fast, actually.
Young, you kind of gave me something
that takes an hour to run a baseline.
So, I'm not going to run this on the
local machine for sure.
But I think initially what we can do is
Yeah, that's the soda run. Cool.
So, um, let me go get both networks
working. We'll get Mr working on this as
well. And then I guess I'll go launch a
couple GPUs worth of this for so it'll
run for an hour. And while that's
running, we'll figure out sweeps,
multiGPU sweeps.
This is going to be a very nice test
environment. Let me say
very hard to find environments that are
like this solid.
I know we're going to have to figure out
some better thing to do with the models.
I'm on one hand, I'm kind of sick of the
LSTM wrapper thing having to like wrap
your policy,
but I guess we'll have to figure out if
there's um it's the least of the evils.
Cool.
This one ran 2 millisecond
to wrap up on pin memory torch thing.
Looks like with your C++ native
multi-threading, it should automatically
batch take advantage. Correct. Anything
else I should look into?
Uh, the only thing we don't have, I
think, is
well,
we're going to have to do the double
buffering or like the end buffering
thing, I think, in C. And then the only
thing I'm not sure with that is once you
have an entire batch of data, I think it
needs to get transferred to the GPU
asynchronously,
which
yeah, that's going to add a little bit
of complexity. I'm going to have to
think about it.
I'm definitely integrating your
threading stuff though, like guaranteed
because I already wrote over the
weekend. I already wrote up the I wrote
a vector interface in C and it works but
it doesn't use threading or anything
right it's just single process but it's
a vector interface so your threading is
going to go into that and then that's
going to get bound back to Python so
that there's the Python version of it
but then there's also going to be uh
this pure C C++ version
I don't know if it's going to be pretty
easy I don't know about that one I'll do
it but I don't know if it's going to be
pretty See,
zero locks, no worker cubes.
That's good. Did you copy the busy
waiting thing?
Okay. So this one is currently this is
slower than the um
uh this is slower than the uh original
architecture but this is zero
optimizations.
This is not unexpected.
Okay, now we should be able to
launch This
first time here what are you working on?
Uh this is live stream for puffer liib.
So I develop high performance
reinforcement learning tools, library
research, all that. And I am currently
working on testing out uh a new
architecture
versus the original baseline on a new
environment that was just merged in
2048.
So actually it's a good time for people
watching. Uh
it's the game of 2048
and we're training very very good agents
to play this and I'm using this as a
benchmark for a couple different neural
net architectures at the moment
because the new architecture I'm testing
would be awesome uh if it works for
puffer 4 but we need some confirmation
there are list of highly wanted type of
end contribution. So the absolute best
thing is if you have experience in
another area and you see the opportunity
to have like a real world application
and you can build like a a cool
prototype environment, that's the best.
Um, but other than that, like if you're
just generally looking for something fun
to do, pretty much whatever low-level
gamedev is chill because it's kind of
unintuitive what environments end up
being useful or not. like 2048 ended up
being a really really good environment
for research.
Generally having environments that are
like challenging or interesting in some
way than the that the current
environments are not is good, but it's
kind of difficult to predict that ahead
of time.
Got to update the website. Yeah, of
course. And then get the new agent onto
the website as well for you.
Is that thing going to load
a 16meg policy? It'll probably load. It
probably just takes 10 seconds. But all
right,
we got to figure out something for that.
Yeah, we'll have to figure something out
for that.
good environments in context of finance.
Uh yes. So we do um
oh macroscopic
we're moving.
Pretty much everything so far has been
trading related. We do a couple things
for that professionally.
It's not like our main area of specialty
or anything, but it's an area where you
can build Sims and build like and run
agents. So, we do
and actually Ray supports 3D rendering.
So, we've got like um we've got this
drone environment. So, this is 3D.
There's actually a drone swarm
environment for this as well. There's uh
this 3D puzzle game.
This is 3D in here. This is pseudo 3D.
We got this one. This is like 3D. Oops.
This is terraforming environment. Top
down but 3D.
A few others.
How is this different from environments
frameworks around gym and stable
baselines? Uh because everything here is
between 100 and a thousand times faster
than stable baselines.
We also have like fundamentally better
algorithms in several areas.
That's not an exaggeration either. We
train millions of steps per second per
GPU.
There's absolutely a risk of
overfitting.
It depends how good your Sim is, right?
So, if you're overfitting to your Sim,
but you have a bad SIM, that's bad. If
you're overfitting to your Sim and your
Sim is the same as the real thing, then
it's not bad.
Sounds great. Yeah. Take a look. It's
all open source. I work on this
full-time.
What happened with this
test binding? S. So cannot open. Ah
right.
Python
for
uh there is one end that's very very
simple that I've been meaning to release
cuz we got permission. The other ones
are not.
The only thing that we really I mean the
main thing that we sell right as a
company the main way that we buy servers
and maintain the project and everything
uh is that we offer custom simulation
development services right
I'm not going to give you more than
vague details of like the types of
projects we've worked on for those and
those are typically not open source.
Oh man, that enong [laughter]
that freaking paper
that was like such a weird paper. That
was basically Salesforce arguing that
they arguing that they should pay more
taxes.
I have no idea where that came from
or how that got okayed.
Oh, so true. Right. Yeah, it makes
sense. Okay.
So is kind of nutty.
Welcome, Lance.
Didn't realize. Yep. Of course.
Yeah, I mean that that's the main thing,
right? So like I kind of like the way
that this project is in the sense that
it's it's a combination of like
everything's open source. Everything is
out in the open. Um I don't have to
charge users anything. I have no impetus
or need to try to monetize users at all.
And at the same time, you know, for
companies that are using RL in really
valuable projects, there are much more
expensive services available around
that.
It's a nice little split.
And lets me spend most of my time just
on research and development, which is
awesome.
reimplementation of carbs. There any
population
selection and resume?
Uh,
so hang on, let me let me answer that.
So, first of all, I don't know what the
heck agile is doing. Do you
Are they Is this one? They have their
own dashboard thingy.
This
Angel
is still alive.
Yeah, they're alive.
Oh, they're doing LM stuff now, though.
Yeah, of course. Um,
I saw their hyper pram stuff. Like,
somebody would have to go try it versus
our own stuff. Um, but what we have,
it's it's kind of like a genetic al, but
it's over the Pareto optimal set of
points. So you're doing like a search an
expansion that is guided by a Gaussian
process and it is around the set of
parto optimal points with respect to
cost and score.
Go on get
Yeah.
If they are using just gym m this it's
it's actually impossible that this is
fast though
yeah but tuna doesn't even have good
algorithms in it
Oh, is this multiple? Okay. So, this is
then they're doing something very
different, right? So, this is um
Yeah, I see. So, they're doing something
that's kind of like um like population
uh based training.
Yeah, they'd be doing something like
population based training for this,
So we don't have carbs though, man. We
So our new algorithm is called protein
and it's an advancement over carbs based
on our own research.
Protein doing though? Do you have any
population checkpointing?
No. So there's the advancements in
protein are not on top of the
population. They're mostly changes to uh
the way that we incorporate Gaussian
processes to guide selection. If you
check on X, I have a blog post on
protein.
So this is Mingru.
I believe this is Mr. and this is
uh Yes. This one should be Mingru.
This one should be LSTM, right?
Yeah.
So yeah, we'll see how these progress
over time
population improve it in your opinion.
Are they doing multiple runs though at
the same time for that? Cuz typically
the populationbased methods they like
they plot it in steps or whatever, but
like the cheat is that they're using a
ton of GPUs for it, right? They're like,
"Oh, it's only one run because they're
doing all their runs in parallel.
I remember that was like the original
thing that it's like yeah it's better if
you treat compute as free
All right, let me use a restroom real
quick. I'm going to get a quick couple
sets in. I should do my daily deadlift.
I've been skipping that too many days.
So, I'll do that and then we will uh
we'll see if we can fix multiGPU sweeps
because I'm going to want to run a full
sweep on this thing to see. I mean, if
this is just better out of the box, then
yay. That saves us a lot of time, but we
need multiGPU sweeps anyways.
I'll leave the charts up.
Be right back.
So, ignore the fact that the pink one is
faster
because the yellow one's going to be
faster uh once it's optimized
because right now you're basically
you're comparing Torch's super optimized
kernel to uh like a completely naive
implementation
in terms of wall talk.
Cool.
We'll leave this over here for when I
need to mess with it.
And uh
we'll probably know in like 15 20
minutes.
In the meantime,
figure out some sweep stuff,
which I think is going to be easiest
just on the other tiny box. Right.
Got two of these multiGPU machines.
Want to just double check because I do
have one rush order that I have to work
on more tonight. Make sure that they're
happy.
Good thing I checked.
One meeting to set up.
Jung, is it supposed to do this wavy
thing
on the baseline?
There like some curriculum shenanigans
going on.
No, looks weird.
Well, that is supposed to be the
baseline.
It's at one bill as well. Yeah. So, it's
supposed to be way better than this.
goes up to seven bill.
Okay. So, what could I have done wrong?
Oh, I suppose um
I should run it with heavy ball Muan,
right?
For comparison.
This is with torches Muan.
So, I guess it's possible that that it's
possible their Muan is just bad.
All right, let's let me go fix that for
you real quick and then we'll
continue.
Well, that's actually a crucial detail,
right? Because
we are going to have to not have heavy
ball in um our C++ either way.
for now. Kung,
I fused it. Yeah.
I still have a bunch of work to do.
the UX.
Okay. Heavy ball is slightly slower,
funny enough.
are you using like new features?
All
I hate
[ __ ] Whatever. We'll see. Hopefully
this doesn't break. [ __ ]
Hey Tim, we are currently trying to get
some real experiments on Mingru.
This will also serve as a check on heavy
on on Muan. I mean Muan vers Heavy Ball.
Nope, just Python mining grew to start.
It's real slow. It'll be faster though,
don't worry.
The puffer will be fast.
World's fastest fish.
All right. So,
I will let these run
and let's figure out
honey box.
Mamba.
Uh, we can still try Mamba
him. I think Mamba's
Well, to be fair, we should still try
it.
Uh, this pretty much matches before.
So we'll see if it's like slower start
one phone.
That's rough.
Yeah. So we will just see if this is
like slow start and then aggressive
takeoff type thing.
I wouldn't be surprised.
That would be interesting though because
that would also imply that we should
retest neural MMO uh with the other
Muan, right?
Well, we're going to try we'll try this
first because I want to see what
happens, right? Is this supposed to be
and is puffer any good at various
stochcastic environments?
uh to the extent that you would expect
RL to be. Yeah,
there's nothing in Puffer that makes it
particularly good or bad at stochastic
specifically. There's plenty in Puffer
that makes it good overall.
Honestly, stocastic is not even really
something that we think about as like a
dedicated challenge.
Okay. So, actually your curve is maybe
06 at 100 mil. It's like Yeah, it is a
very slow takeoff. So, maybe it is
right, you know.
Maybe it's just this is a slower
takeoff.
Oh, but this is six.
This is 600. Yeah, this is supposed to
be way better. What happened?
Why is it so much screwier?
Oh, wait. Did I do three layers?
I might have done three layers. Let me
see.
That's how it goes. him.
Uh,
is there anything else I could have
messed up in here? Kung at 16ks,
512 hidden,
So this is your G2048. I didn't change
this at all.
Encode observations decode actions.
And then all I did, let's see. So this
gets hidden size, right?
So I pass
hidden size to this. And then I just
call
uh Comput obser or was it encode
observations and decode actions?
Well, it's not debris because this is a
tuned run where we know that in
Kyouung's run of this, it does weigh
better. So, there's some discrepancy
that's not that.
Okay, this is the mining group one. I
know for sure this one is wrong
Yeah,
but I had your LSTM correct, so I don't
know how it's still messed up.
boss curves and there shouldn't have
been any changes
to that.
It's possible that I have changes to the
implementation in this version.
Doesn't look like it though.
Yeah, this is our normal implementation.
This is how I implemented the minimum
learning rate or the coin and nailing
which would seem fine to me. Oh, you
know what it is? It's not many batches.
I got it. It's got to be this.
The only thing that changed from version
to version.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's definitely this
here. Let me fix this.
So this is going to be um 4 m
is this times 4090
x times and then your batch size
is going to just be BPT horizon
64.
Holy holy batch size. Um,
okay. So, num many batches needs to be
32.
Okay, so this is unbelievably slow.
Very cool.
Guaranteed I messed it up on neural MMO
as well.
Okay, cool. So, we'll be able to see the
results from this pretty soon
3.7 mil pram
set numbum mini batches.
Yeah, I did numb I total batch over mini
batch size. Yeah. So this is because in
Puffer 4, you no longer set epochs. You
set mini batches
by default.
And I should absolutely have an auto
option for this as well because like
very often you want it to be one um you
very often want one update, one epoch
worth. But
this is why it's a dev version, not
released yet.
working on it.
All right, we'll see what these guys do
in a second
and then uh we will continue on parallel
stuff.
What did they do the algorithm that I
just post a random graph's
also like one of the people who I I
respect more than anybody else in the
field.
He's pretty awesome.
That seems a lot more mini batches than
normal.
Yeah, cuz the batch is gigantic, man.
Kung's using batch size 1 million. So,
I'm not here to question. I'm only here
to replicate today.
The parameters matched perfectly this
time.
Yeah, this is 200.
200 mil
supposed to be better than this by now.
It's way below that.
All right, Kong. Why is this thing
different?
Is it supposed to be 3.7 million
parameters? Is that correct?
>> Okay.
So I have your network architecture.
Sure.
Oh, now it optimizes.
Let's see if it optimizes way worse than
before, though, or something.
Okay. Yeah, this is like way worse than
before with a new heavy ball versus with
torch.
Interesting.
What is What's not getting applied? I
bet it's like the learning rate not
getting a yield or something.
I don't see anything wrong with this
though.
This is cosine and kneeling, right?
This is the formula for cosine and
nailing.
I can check this. I could go chuck
theuler back on it, I suppose.
But this is the formula for it now.
Is this supposed to be on heavy ball
momentum?
There we go. Immediate difference right
there. All right, we just broke the
optimizer is all.
So, kind of crazy then that we managed
to get um
we managed to get a run of neural MMO to
do something.
What
is this actually? True or is this bait?
Whoa,
Dude,
that's so cool.
And good on Riot as well.
Really, really good on Riot
for not just like killing it in
corporate hell.
Let's see what happens with this thing,
man.
The mining grew is going to be four
layers. Four layer min.
And this will be a stable learning
experiment.
Okay, we'll give this a few minutes
and uh we will figure out whether we're
back on track or not.
Get a quick
quick set or two in.
Ah, there we are. That's a proper
learning curve.
There we are. There's a proper learning
curve.
Let's uh merge this before we forget and
then we will figure out why multiGPU
weird
So, Kyouung, your uh your environment is
now or your
well your modified environment at the
very least is now getting used in uh
proper proper baselines.
Oh, yeah.
There we are.
We shall see how this goes.
It'll be quite interesting.
And we actually can go fix neural MMO as
well at the same time, right?
Oh, of course I didn't set nin many
batches.
Of course.
All right. So, this is 8k.
8192 * 64
divided by 32768
is 16 mini batches. Would you look at
that? I did it wrong.
Um
16 mini batches.
Oh, actually no. That was right. That's
the default. Cool. Is it just the
optimizer then?
The optimizer being jank.
layers
expansion factor. Yeah, this is all
correct.
Oh, but this is literally um
not even like a neural MMO mining group,
is it?
neural MMO. A lot of steps. Lot of lot
of lot of steps.
Maybe we just wait. Yeah, we're gonna
just wait on this one because we're
going to need to do the multiGPU
anyways.
Just wait.
Okay, look at this. So, we have this one
here,
this one here, and we'll see how these
two progress.
sweep to Tetris.
Yeah. And we're going to we're about to
see whether we can get all this stuff on
neural MMO.
Neural MMO and 2048 will be the two hard
benchmark M.
this advertising QFA subscription
culture and Microsoft
Where's the multiGPU? It's on the docks,
right?
Uh well, it's going to take a long time
with this version, obviously.
Normally, it's like a three-day run.
We have extra boxes. We're gonna do 2048
at the same time, man.
How did you run sweep on neural MMO?
Very slowly.
Oh yeah. So, this was this weird thing.
I don't know why this is doing this.
got to be like some common torch bug,
right?
data parallel no attribute just okay
cool. So we have the uh the command at
least
I got to hate com I got to hate the
distributed [ __ ] Come on.
Really, really, really obnoxious heavy
ball.
But we don't want to use uh torch muon,
right?
because it wasn't working nicely.
Well, [sighs] why does it do this [ __ ]
man?
Oh, this is
totally fine.
Let me see if it works with the
original.
Yeah, you see Kung
a pain in the ass.
And you have to wait because I'm going
to have to go look at the code and see
what's different with these two
implementations. And the source is
somehow even worse than torches source.
It's like functional hell.
Okay.
1 million.
That seems really bad, doesn't it?
why are we so slow? Cuz we're stuck in
the environment loop. Five
or
good too.
is like it's just there's hell to pay
and there's no one else to pay
Okay, this seems to uh this seems to run
at the very least. And if I run it in
distributed,
not bad at all.
4 mil.
They're uh right up there behind me. You
can see them.
Okay, so this works. Now the question
is,
what is different?
Can we go figure out what the heck heavy
ball is doing?
Korean man. I'm not dealing with AMD
[ __ ]
We can just make this thing not try to
compile.
Does this take star quarks?
Can we just do
still breaks.
Dang.
Well, now we have to go figure out
what's wrong with this.
What do you mean?
This this whole library is like insane
functional shenanigans.
Well, it's actually it's not it's weird.
It's like simultaneously crazy
functional and crazy objectoriented.
Just Muan. Well, yeah, but there's the
torch muon, right?
And the but and like the torch muan
doesn't match this somehow.
But like my the thing is my muon is not
the same as Heavy Ball Muan. It's the
same as uh PyTorch's Muan, which
apparently wasn't working the same.
Go take a look at our run, by the way.
Oh, okay. Look at this.
These two are on par at the moment.
Well, yes. Provided we make men grow
fast. Absolutely.
Yeah, I'm sorry, Lucas. This code's just
insane, my guy.
This is like crazy functional and crazy
object-oriented at the same time.
Anyone see my muan
Monday?
>> [snorts]
>> Well, I ported this already the other
day, man. This is what I ported to C++.
Plus, plus
wait. Decay.
That probably not good.
Did I catch this though?
Maybe. Did I catch this or not?
So, actually what we're going to do next
is I'm going to try
we're going to try to match the learning
curves on 2048 so that we can get this
run going today uh with torches muon.
That would be ideal.
procedural man.
It's just procedural.
Just write the code top to bottom in the
simplest way possible. Done.
That's it.
That's stable.
Nice and stable.
We're going to try a lot of stuff. Kung,
hold on.
might get rid of the two-phase system.
What? Two phase
See how we're doing here.
Oh yeah.
Is this expected?
0.55 PF.
3.4 billion.
We have spare GPUs on this machine.
So, I'm going to try some additional
things without killing these runs.
I'm going to do
I will check in one second. I'm not
killing the runs, Kung. I'm just
launching more runs on the other cards.
If this matches, then we'll be able to
use um
move on.
school to learn AI. You better learn
well.
The market for people who don't really
know what they're doing is a bubble. The
market for people who do know what
they're doing is not a bubble.
Reach 32K. So, nobody has reached 64k
yet, Kyouong. And uh we've got
reaching a 32K here.
What's your streaming app?
Uh, I don't know if you need a pro
account, man, but I'm just I'm streaming
through a reream to X uh YouTube and
Twitch.
Okay. So, it's going to be at least
several minutes before we have any sort
of indication on this, but this is still
going up. A little wavy. Still going up.
Fuel
three. I want to have this thing done by
four.
Not using OBS. Yeah, I'm using OBS. And
then it goes OBS is synced to Reream.
And Reream multiccasts it to uh Twitch,
YouTube, and X
like
infinite tunnel incoming.
you have neural MMO 3 mining going. Uh,
we will in a bit. I want to make sure
that the I want to see if we can get
this to match. And then we're going to
do a 6GPU neural MMO min
which I think we can get about four or
five billion steps an hour on that.
It'll be slow but not unbearably slow.
I'm actually, you know, in the meantime,
let's see, um,
let's see if multiGPU sweeps works in
the meantime.
Python
mult
is instance of param
dict.
never had a multiGPU.
Each run use only one GPU.
Yeah, each run only uses one GPU.
There's not really any reason to try to
use multiple GPUs for networks this
small.
Like, there really isn't, man.
How the hell is this thing at 6.1,000
steps per second?
Not having a max cost on this thing is
nuts.
Like it just launches a ridiculous job
with params that's going to make it take
forever for no reason.
It seems bad to not have a max cost to
me.
Yeah, it has a max suggestion cost.
Sure.
But like, okay, first of all, it's not
set for Pong to be lower. And second of
all, the max suggestion cost is just
based on an estimate, right? So that's a
pruned cost. It doesn't actually prevent
it from running that long, right?
Yeah, see it's not used in here. So,
what I had is I had it like this
where it just cuts runs off after a
certain amount of time.
How do you have it so that Pong doesn't
like run forever?
Cuz like it immediately set up some
stupidly long run just by sampling like
a tiny number of M's when I ran it.
Well, sweep runs train every time,
right?
Oh, you just don't sweep very small
number of M's.
Oh, this is the old PR.
Okay, I await your message.
Max cost looks like it belongs under
train arg.
Uh, that is valid.
Yeah, I could definitely put it under
train args and then it would be shared
across sweeps.
It's not at the moment, but I could very
easily do that and it would be better.
You're right.
It probably sampled like 5 m or
something, man. Look, I have it so that
Pong can sample all the way down to a
minimum number of M's.
So, I don't think relying on the shitty
Gaussian process to uh to make sure you
don't waste a ton of compute is a good
idea.
I mean like one if you have asynchronous
having or something right if you have
some sort of detection mechanism then I
I agree that you don't need this
roger I don't beta test all the genai
models
I like I think compared to most people
you like uh you see doing dev I
generally use them very little. The main
thing that I use at the moment, I use
Super Maven, which is getting killed in
a few weeks. And then I use uh Sarah,
which serves like not amazing models,
but they're very fast.
And that's it.
So like what's your recommendation here,
Kung? Because I can see two things,
right? I think that it's like we either
put in we either just don't sweep a tiny
number of M's which is not great.
Um or we can do
we can replace the max suggestion cost
which is a sweep arg with a max train
cost like a max train time which is a
train arg. So it's a hard threshold
end like hidden it is pow two look
it is sampling powers of two here
but the point is that this could be a
valid run
right because like in 40 we want to also
be able to do sample efficiency
experiments
I guess the easiest thing for now.
I mean, the the thing that's actually
going to work though is just adding max
cost to train, right?
Like this is the thing that's actually
going to work.
Well, it's going to be different
perfume.
So, I'd put it so that if it's not
specified, there is no max cost.
You know,
protein
Yeah, this one we get rid of because
it's
This is not good.
Go on.
Well, now I actually have to go freaking
figure out the differences, don't I?
Sucks.
Oh, okay. It's an estra of momentum, not
nest of EMA.
Okay,
that's annoying. So that then means that
we need
the heavy ball version until we
can test these equal
I have nestrov equals
enables nest of momentum
momentum factor
0.95.
So this one looks good.
Uh mining grew so far matches
which is great actually.
And then it's just a question of the
optimizer.
No, it hasn't reached 65k. Well, maybe
this one has. Let's see.
I guess we just figure out why the hell
heavy ball's broken for now.
Is there no buffer size in this Kung?
No buffer.
I guess I just did a bad merge.
We can see if this works with heavy
ball, I suppose.
No buffer size. Cool.
Okay, so this works.
Um, I guess I just write a test,
honestly.
Did I say to [ __ ] like change this?
No
thing. LR apps.
That doesn't change anything. Yeah,
super annoying.
just keep heavy ball for a while, which
is annoying.
At least will give us one confident
test.
Uh cuz it looks like they did stop.
Let's see why.
I mean, they look good regardless, but
why the hell did they stop?
Oh, one hour max cost. Lovely.
cuz they took an hour.
I mean, let's just check if uh if
they're the same at
for Bill
4.2 to bell.
Yeah. Same thing, right?
61. Yeah.
Right on target.
The same curve.
And then these two are the ones that are
messed up.
let's really quick just write a uh
report this thing so we can actually use
it.
H I see
why they write their code like this.
Why they got to be weird?
Windows switch
top three
which I do ML switch from notebooks to
Python CLI just grab invid I mean grab
uh grab a buntu it's the easiest the
best supported thing
and yes if you're doing any sort of
serious engineering you should not be
working in notebooks
There are a very few select scientists
like very good scientists who work out
of notebooks. Um and all of them that I
know were supported very heavily by a
bunch of engineers to actually do the
engineering.
I got to go in a few minutes folks. Um
so
just uh before I forget this is all open
source. I do this type of stream and dev
pretty much every day. Puffer.ai. If you
want to support the project, you can
star the repo right here. It helps a
lot. Uh all the devs on Discord, join
there if you want to get involved. And
you can follow me on X for more content,
including my educational stuff.
What the heck did they do?
What did they do?
contributing puffer. Yeah, the easiest
thing is to grab a buntu and then just
use the docker because it has everything
preset up for you.
Um,
you can also do from source with UV
that'll also work
And Muan is just funk, which single
tensor muan
is not single tensor muan because this
is dumb as hell. Uh,
how's this thing supposed to work?
Code
in it group.
Oh wait, it calls.
Yes, this is needed actually.
the vinet group
like this.
Well, that's the start of an
implementation.
I'm going to have to do some more work
on this in the evening, but I also have
some client stuff to take care of. Oh
[ __ ] I totally forgot.
Okay, never mind. Lucky me. I forgot to
check an email, but I'm good.
I told somebody I was free at 4 or six,
and luckily I didn't. Uh, luckily they
said six.
No harm, no foul.
What happens when I get absorbed though
in um
in this stuff?
Thank you folks for tuning in. Um, I
will be back tomorrow morning. I have
some client stuff to work on tonight and
then uh I'm going to see if I can at
some point carve out some additional
time to make some progress here.
At the very least,
we have some very strong evidence that
the um the new architecture is in fact
good
and that actually the only problem that
we're having is um not being able to
match the old optimizer. So anyways,
uh anything else?
Oh, I think that is Yep, that's it. All
right. Thank you. See you.